i am max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
lots to get to stacy yes
well you know we've been talking about
the cantillianaire class
over the past few years since the money
printer started going
since the central bank started printing
credit
for the to bail out the global financial
system
and now sock gen society general has
actually quantified how much just how
much
of trillions of dollars has been
transferred to
the top one percent who own the vast
majority of stocks and bonds so
how much of the stock markets rise over
the last 11 years
is due to qe here's an estimate
the s p 500 would be trading closer to
1800 without fed
bond buying says society general right
now it's at 3 500
it should be at 1800 if it weren't for
the fed
buying up all the basically the bad
assets off the bank's balance sheets
yeah this has a lot of implications okay
so without the money printing the
markets would be 50 60
lower okay that's point number one point
number two
is that as a contingent effect that
means that
myself i own stocks bonds and gold and
bitcoin
that means that the markets uh exist as
a transfer mechanism
so the fed can't just print money for me
individually
they print it so that executives buy
back their own stocks
of stocks that i own and then i benefit
accordingly and as you point out
90 of the population doesn't have stocks
bonds
and these types of assets to the extent
that
those like myself and others might have
uh
and so that's the next point is that
companies who buy back their own stock
and the executives who run these
companies say
remember if you have options on your
stock and the stock and you know
guaranteed there's no risk the stock's
going to go higher the options can go
from a dollar to a hundred dollars or
so an executive can make 50 100 million
200 million
that's why we have so many billionaires
in america is by
playing this game of guaranteed upside
by money printing and owning the options
on your own
stock and so if you strip out those
numbers
you would have markets that are a lot
lower you'd have a lot more
parity between uh classes in america you
wouldn't have the wealth and income gap
you wouldn't have the social unrest
and you wouldn't have a lot of these
other problems so it's very stark
very plain to see for those who want to
see right we're going to show you some
charts to show you
visibly how how big it is but in terms
of
kind of a lean duck president coming in
biden who's
you know very very old and doesn't have
the senate
and and has reduced his majority in the
congress
remember jerome powell had said last
week that uh we need more fiscal
stimulus because all i can do
at the fed is create these
cantillionaires and so
here we're having a situation where
there will be no free money for the
people
because there's no you know you don't
have a populist vibrant young
leader who might be around for many
years and you're gonna like you want to
be in his favor if you're in the senate
might want to do some deals but
there's no will to do some deals because
you don't want to give
the the lame duck president any you know
points that you yourself when you're in
power
want to achieve so you know the sock gen
data
again they said so the stock market the
s p 500
is at 3 500 it should be at 1800 and
they say that the nasdaq
should be closer to 5 000 than 11 000
which is totally remarkable and just to
show you the charts on this
this is the s p 500 where it is and
that's where it should be the red line
if it weren't for qe and nasdaq 100
that you see the huge gap there and of
course gaps usually close
should this quantitative easing ever end
if it ever
can end right that that's like a whole
another
story to cover but let's compare
biden he comes into office potentially
and this means that i believe we're
going to see a repeat of 2008 remember
obama took office and because obama was
a pretty young guy at the time and
didn't come through finance
he was a law student and very good with
constitutional law but he didn't know
anything about wall street
he kind of threw the keys of wall street
over larry summers and all these other
folks
and they went ahead and they created the
global financial crisis
um after effects that seemed to benefit
the contillionaires in a remarkable way
remember the billionaires after the 2008
crisis all
quadrupled and or more their wealth
while
the vast waves of american population
went bankrupt and lost their house
so i'm pretty sure we're going to see a
repeat of that with biden that's why
they say from 11 years ago 2008 when
obama was elected that's the point where
it starts and that's
those are the trillions of dollars you
know that gap represents
trillions of dollars trillions and
that's why they're so wealthy and you're
not
and of course like as we've already
covered on election night
when you know it took a few days
afterward to determine
uh you know to declare a winner but at
that night when
trump was ahead the chinese currency
crashed
and then when it was biden it soared so
you know that is something that ordinary
you know the deplorable people across
this country have to consider
that this is the system they're stuck
with for the next four years china
continues to eat your lunch
and you aren't even going to get free
money there is going to be no mmt
for all there's just going to be more
cantillionaires created
and and stockgen also looks at the bond
market
and and they're saying by the way that
you know it's the fed buying all these
bonds
that drives up the risk appetite which
is
indirectly then causing the stock market
to soar
so in the bond market this is what the
10-year treasury should be instead
for their part the sock gen analysts
using a mix of weekly
macroeconomic indicators running back to
took a stab at estimating the effect of
the fed's bond buying effort
on the benchmark 10-year treasury yield
no
they concluded that qe likely knocked
around 180 basis points or 1.8
percentage points off the 10-year
yield so again putting it into this
historical context
the 10-year yield in an american economy
that
is capitalist and is um
foundationally constructed on a central
bank and banking system
feeding into the entrepreneurial class
the long-term rates are traditionally
and you can make a strong case for them
to be without equivocation around four
to five percent
that gives savers enough money to save
for retirement if they work hard in the
economy
when the fed started buying back these
bonds and dropping rates to near zero
they transferred trillions
of cash from savers you know your mom
and your dad
out there they probably have called you
grandpa they called you up and said hey
you know my retirement account dropped
80 90
of income that was this wholesale
thievery going on
by moving that capital to wall street
who then used it to speculate
and as they point out about their
comment about risk the de-risking of the
economy in other words if you know
beforehand when you before the rule-out
wheel stops that it's going to land on
red then you know you're going to put a
lot of a lot of money on red
when wall street knows that as as was
said during the 2008 crisis the news
that
goldman sachs got ahead of everyone else
that the bailout was coming
allowed them to go all in and they
quadruple their wealth overnight again
so that
that's money that's been extracted from
the real economy
using this uh machination of a
pass-through mechanism
that looks like a market economy but
it's actually a rigged
kind of way to feed billions to your
friends
right of course when you just talked
about grandpa you know and their pension
being eaten by
the fed's quantitative easing policy
i i thought of chen uger of of of
the young turks he tweeted that he was
so glad to have like a grandpa
in office and i was like this guy still
has to work
because of the fed's qe policy like
that's why we have
this you know this gerontocracy as they
call it here in america
yeah and remember they're replacing
capitalism based on
the supply and demand free market
economics with
what they call progressivism like so
they're trying to base an economy
on progressivism just uh bad economics
they wanted to do
mmt they're not going to be able to do
that but remember on the campaign trail
the in the very last week what
what where biden and harris having to
say they love fracking they love
fracking and this is the bad economics
that again
kaiser report has been right for years
on this because not only did the fed
encourage this
the growth not even encouraged but
created the growth of this
cantillionaire class
and encouraged risk taking and forced
pension funds into risky assets
and they forced pension funds into
private equity funds that were invested
in what shale okay well you know buy it
and love shale
but i'll tell you what exxon mobil which
used to be the biggest company in the
world
the biggest american company in the
world and now it's being displaced by
high tech of course but
exxon warns of 30 billion
shale write down a decade after buying
xto again this goes
back to that 2011 period you know the 11
years ago
period that all this cheap money the
quantitative easing drove people into
the shale sector
which never made money ever even when
interest rates are zero
even when oil prices were over a hundred
even all of that stuff and they never
ever made money
so you know people will tell us we're
wrong and they'll tell
exxon they're wrong for writing down the
30 billion dollars
you know how much exxon how much how
many shares are in pension funds in
grandpa's pension fund
uh you know they were having to write
down their shale investment because
of the patriotic fervor that was
happening that and and this delusion
that there was somehow
that this was a great investment because
the yields were so high and blah blah
blah
right seventy percent of all fracking
rigs begin life
negative cash flow and never make money
the remaining thirty percent
end up losing money within three years
the industry
as a whole is cash flow negative and is
only exist for one reason
to allow wall street to create junk
bonds to sell into pension funds
and they miss sell they do not state
that those bonds and if you look at
those junk bonds for pension for
shale industry and notice that they're
all catastrophically down and they all
will go to zero
and then what will the politicians say
particularly those who are saying we
love fracking
oh that's right they forgot to take the
pencil and a piece of paper
and add two plus two and come up with
four
the politicians whoever is in office
will say two plus two is actually
uh uh we're not sure so
sorry but sorry if you're sorry that
you're poor
i guess that's the that's the meme of
the week right sorry you're poor no
it's called have fun staying for have
fun staying poor
that's the meme of the week so if you're
in the shell business have fun staying
poor
well energy stocks have lost 50 percent
more value than the s p
500 has the biggest drop of any sector
going back to 1928
which was like just a decade before
biden was born
so i think it's like it's quite
interesting that this is like
a full circle this this industry this
era is over
we're at the end of fiat uh at zero
percent we're zero bound we're hit
we've hit zero the dollar is over um uh
biden came into office
in 1972 just after we went off the gold
center so
it's just coming full circle and we're
going to sleep
and who who beats us in high tech of
course is china
and that's what the market said is where
that's what the market said
it has been decided in this election
right i think the
current whoever is in the white house
going forward there's a bit of a poison
chalice
because they're going to be in power
during uh
the worst collapse ever in history i
think there's a 99
chance of that well there's a 100 chance
we're going to take a break and when we
come back
much more coming your way
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to go to lynn alden
of
lynn alden investment strategy lynn
welcome to the kaiser report
hey thanks for having me i love your
show oh excellent so
jerome powell is as we're having this
interview he's testifying before
congress
and um his one of his comments i wanted
to get your comment on
um he says that fiscal policy is
absolutely essential here he's kind of
throwing it back to congress and saying
you know we need
we need to address fiscal policy so what
does he mean when he says that
so that has to do with the transmit the
transmission mechanism for
uh you know the asset purchases that he
wants to do so for example
when the fed buys uh you know uh
treasuries mortgage-backed securities or
apple bonds or whatever the case may be
uh that doesn't really get out to the
average person right so that that's
that's mostly you know a liquidity
uh boosts up asset prices uh but you
know
uh you know large fiscal deficits
whether it's in the form of stimulus
checks or other things
uh can get out to the you know the
average person uh so basically the you
know the federal reserve here they've
already done
uh you know wait wait like a bunch of
different programs for monetary policy
uh but they can't really target uh you
know to to individuals the way
uh that the treasury can so what he's
basically saying is you know they want
he wants the treasure to do more of the
targeting
uh and then the fed's role would be to
you know to finance that to buy the
bonds as needed
uh to maintain a liquid treasury market
it's an interesting
uh phenomenon because he has been doing
money printing
uh over there at the fed uh by the
trillions and trillions of dollars
uh he's saying now that we can't get it
to individuals
you've got to work on that over there in
congress
concurrently with that we see that the
velocity of money
has been collapsing for years
up until recently maybe there's a slight
change but you can comment on that
what does that tell us uh when the fed's
saying we're trying to create inflation
by printing trillions for years but
the velocity keeps going down are they
how come they keep doing that what's
what's going on here well so if you look
at money velocity that you know that
most refers to the broad money supply
and the fed only has partial control
over that so when they print money
uh that mostly gets in the bank reserves
uh and the two ways that that broad
money supply can increase are either
banks lend it to
individuals and corporations and boost
the broad money supply that way
or uh the federal government runs these
massive deficits that are monetized by
the fed
uh and of course this year we saw the
the second uh of that so we saw you know
the the treasury ran very large uh
deficits
uh and a large portion of that treasury
issuance was purchased by the the fed so
instead of extracted from the economy
somewhere from taxes or lending
and then put back the economy somewhere
else it was extracted from nowhere it
was extracted from new dollars
and then inserted elsewhere in the
economy so we saw this big increase in
the money supply
uh but we haven't seen you know we've
seen a gdp
uh decreased this year because of
pandemic and because of
you know there's a variety of factors
there so there's wealth concentration
generally results in lower velocity
and also aging demographics and
technology increases so we're seeing
basically that broad money supply is
going up a lot faster than gdp over the
long run
and that's why we're seeing velocity go
down and you mentioned a couple of
things
there about bank lending and wealth
concentration
so the banks are not lending that
creates velocity when bank
a lends to bank b and then bank b lends
to bank c
you know that creates velocity of money
and um
with interest rates at zero percent and
um
with no blending from bank to bank
velocity goes down that would suggest
that
there's no demand for money there's no
demand for credit
and yet in the united states there are
millions of entrepreneurs who are always
looking for
capital to start businesses um
and then you mentioned wealth hoarding
and
so my question is are banks
hoarding wealth in a way that they're
not making it available to
small to medium-sized enterprises
which is walk us through how they're
able to do that because if interest
rates are so low as they are today and
we know
that there's millions of entrepreneurs
who want to
to do business what are the banks doing
how do they get away with that it seems
to me like they're
doing something that is economically
unsound or
on the dodgy side of things what do you
say to this
well yeah the challenge is so from the
bank's perspective they just want to
maximize their profits
and so whenever they look at a loan
they're looking at the risks and the
potential rewards from it
and so when you have very low interest
rates uh you know the overall upside is
pretty much capped
uh whereas the risk is still meaningful
that they could lose the entire loan if
it's a bad loan
and so you know there are some places
where we're actually seeing
you know for example if you look at
credit card interest rates uh they're
extraordinarily high and that's because
you know that's an area that hasn't
really been held down artificially
uh so that market generally represents
more the true risk of that sort of
lending
where they're lending out but then
they're getting really high interest
rates in return
uh whereas when you look at the mortgage
sector or when you look at corporate
loans or
you know smaller personal loans business
loans uh basically the the rates are
pretty low
and so the credit worthy demand for that
uh is somewhat lacking
uh and just the way that things are set
up now you know part of why we've seen
you know what what many people have
called a k-shaped recovery
is that large businesses they can access
capital markets whether it's bond
issuance
uh you know even with the fed you know
helping to push down yields
they can get access to capital whereas
as you pointed out small businesses
uh you know they're seen as a lot more
kind of higher risk
uh and they're more reliant on banks and
just banks haven't seen it in their
favor
uh you know the cost benefit analysis to
do a lot of lending in that area they're
worried about
you know the customers of that business
if they're going to be there or not
and you know basically if you look at
lowering interest rates uh
in some cases it can be stimulative but
only to a point because if you get to a
low enough interest rate
it's not like you know going from two
percent to one percent is going to make
you take out a loan that you weren't
otherwise going to take out
so for example back when there's higher
inflation and higher rates
going down from eight percent to five
percent could be stimulative
but when we're down here near the zero
bound uh lower and lower rates this
increased reliance on monetary policy
this doesn't really do a lot there's not
there's not it's not really getting out
more into the economy
right i i get that um what what troubles
me a bit is that
banks are in the business of making
loans
that's what they do yeah and they're not
making the loans so if i let's say i'm a
shop owner and i sell tomatoes and i get
wholesale delivery of tomatoes from the
farm
and i decide i'm not going to sell my
tomatoes today i'm going to hoard them
because the price of tomatoes is going
up and people
end up starving so then there's a case
to be made that you're that's a bad
actor
in the economy they're not fulfilling
their role as a merchant
so banks they're not fulfilling their
role as a bank would it make
sense for the government perhaps to
introduce a public option and say look
we're going to have a bank that makes
loans that doesn't hoard the cash
that doesn't increase wealth uh
concentration
and doesn't try to game the system all
the time as we've discovered from some
of these big banks that have to pay
fines
all the time for cheating does
does it make sense to have a public bank
like that i mean in europe for example
you go to the post office and borrow
money
you know the post office is also a bank
uh and they don't com
it's just a bank right we don't have any
real banks in this country lynn no i
think there's a case made for that i
mean that's definitely one policy option
uh so far we saw this year is that they
did something similar with you know the
ppp
loan program uh but of course they
structured it so went through the banks
so banks got a cut of that uh but it was
essentially you know the fed the i mean
the treasury and the fed were basically
backstopping
uh you know the risks of the banks and
so one way to look at it if you look at
uh you know
bank holdings of treasury securities
they're at multi-decade highs right now
so basically instead of lending to the
broad public
banks are buying treasuries and lending
to the federal government and then the
federal government is basically
you know running these big deficits and
getting it out you know in some ways to
the public
so basically banks are lending but
through all they're only choosing the
absolute safest uh
assets rather than uh going out and
lending to small businesses and other
things like that of course it comes down
to any
individual banks so some banks you know
these these large money center banks for
example are very different than a small
regional bank
uh that specializes in certain types of
loans uh many of them for example
have been called out in bad energy loans
right there are some banks that that
specialize in that and they've been
you know by basically making all those
loans that so they're they were
punishment for actually doing the loans
whereas other banks are just holding
back and not lending at all
so it really comes down to individual
banks some of them are kind of
uh you know more aggressive than they
should be in areas that are just not
economic
and other ones they could be doing more
and they're just choosing to go with a
really kind of low risk route of buying
treasuries and holding reserves
you know you mentioned wealth
concentration and we talked about the
dynamics of banks and the fed
and how the money circulates another
term often
heard this year and last few years is
the cantillon effect
uh okay this is it speaks to wealth
concentration
and how this money does or does not
circulate um
is is is that part of the banking
plumbing
the that can tell an effect is that an
underlying cause
of a lot of the the wealth concentration
but now we're seeing a lot of social
unrest
that's coming with that wealth
concentration and and the divide and
disparity in society can can can we
point to the concern effect and say look
this is a primary cause of this
lin no i think that's a big part of it
yeah and if you look at you know over
the long term
uh we've had basically rising wealth
inequalities since you know about 40
years 45 years or so ever since around
the mid 70s it started to go up
and you know there's a variety of
factors for that there's fiscal policy
there's monetary policy there's all
sorts of reasons you know there's
technology
uh that basically takes something we've
had a uh you know geopolitics this this
big kind of offshoring movement we've
had
uh that really accelerated in the 90s so
all these factors are basically coming
to a head
uh over the past several years you know
when you run into the zero bound
uh and when you know we've already
offshored a big part of our
manufacturing base
uh basically yeah if you're if you're if
you're close to the the money sources
you're doing okay this year
uh but if you work uh you know if you're
farther from those resources
uh you know many of these businesses are
out of luck right so if you're for
example a large restaurant chain
and you can access capital markets you
can get the financing you need to stay
liquid in this environment
uh whereas if you're a small kind of
family-run restaurant
it's much harder for you to get
financing and so you're further from the
money source
and so we've seen a very large number of
closures for example of small businesses
and family restaurants they mentioned
the early 1970s of course in 1971 nixon
closed the gold window we went into an
all fiat world
and this was an echo and a response to
back in the 40s with the creation
of the brenton woods agreement after
world war ii and trying to
architect the global economy in ways and
that that time it was tied to gold now
the imf a week before has said now
they're looking to do a new brenton
woods uh the global standard the dollar
standard turns 50.
um what do you anticipate with this
new brenton woods the imf is calling
about the
what how will that change things lin
what we're already seeing over the past
couple years uh more and more kind of a
decentralization
uh so for example if you look at uh
trade between russia and china over the
past two years
uh it's really de-dollarized uh so that
used to be you know most like 80
of the 85 of the trade was in dollars uh
over the past two years that shifted to
something like 45 percent of their trade
in dollars
uh and you know of course now we've seen
iran for example potentially
using bitcoin to go around some
sanctions uh and so
we're seeing more of these kind of off
dollar channels already developing
so my base case going forward is that
that's going to continue in some way
that we're going to see kind of a
diversification uh in
in payment networks including for for
oil which is a big part of this you know
petrodollar system
now i i think that there are these going
to be these potential uh you know
uh pushes for uh reform or like a second
bread and woods
to see if polymath policymakers can try
to unify that
uh but that you know the trouble there
of course is that you know
now we have kind of an increasingly
multipolar world so why you know it's
going to be hard to get countries to
agree on things especially countries
that feel that they're benefiting from
the current system
uh and so you know whether or not any of
that goes through
we're already seeing some of a
fracturing and a decentralization
of of you know what how global trade is
done right hey we're gonna do a second
part with you but that's it for this
edition
thanks for being on lynn thanks for
having me all right that's going to do
it for this edition of kaiser report
with me max keiser and stacey herbert
want to thank our guest
lynn alden of lynn alden investment
strategy
until next time bye y'all
you